cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
let me play this video clown World
posted this clip that's been that's made
the rounds for a few years and I'm going
to play here yeah it came back recently
but I'm going to play for you here uh
this is your proof that we are dealing
with a Cults hope you enjoy
about racism anti
I will use my voice in the most
uplifting way possible
and do everything in my power to educate
my community this is called a profession
of Faith Yep this is like the Nicene
Creed 100.
my white ones look at what they're
worshiping with their hands they got
their face muscles on there they're
professionals
this is a cult there is no so uh let's
let's talk about a religion versus a
cult religions and this is what's funny
because they like to call there's a lot
of people who like to call Christianity
a cult and I'm like well maybe when I
was 17 I might have said something like
that but then you learn about the
prominent and well-respected
philosophers of olden days who happen to
be Christians their teachings their
writings very very brilliant things were
written by many people who were
Christian Catholic or otherwise and we
still look to these when we reference
law blackstone's formulation for
instance which lends to the fifth and
sixth amendments I mean a a plethora of
the of the of the Bill of Rights
actually and it's rooted in the story of
Sodom and Gomorrah in the Bible you we
have a religion where people are asking
deep philosophical moral and spiritual
questions you have a cult which does
none of those things doesn't believe in
any of it blindly follows without
question these people are worshiping
nothing
nothing there's no tenets there's no
moral framework there there's no
there's nothing to live by just the
power of those who are the high priests
and Priests of the cult that's why it's
a cult and they're five minutes of hate
don't forget about their five minutes
yes thank you or well yes absolutely and
by the way you know they have their
hands in the air and as you say Tim
they're worshiping nothing but they're
in this secular Rapture and what they're
repeating is all words of love and
tolerance use your voice for good they
are the most vicious
intolerant uh uh monsters on the face of
the Earth not everybody a lot of these
people just get sucked in they don't
even know what they're doing but the
leaders leading these kinds of movements
are the most vicious and evil and we
should talk about all this stuff in
spiritual terms evil is at the root of
so much of what we say and let's let's
be real here because I can already hear
the the defense from many of these
liberal leftist types and I hate call
them liberals because they're not really
liberal saying like oh in religions
didn't have colds and blow Bloods like
dude look a lot of people were killed in
the name of God you name the religion
and there's religious conflict of War
zealots and cult-like behavior and
really awful things I'm simply saying
there's a difference between a cult and
a religion there seems to be a purpose
to a religion there are Bad actors and
there are good actors just like they are
good humans and bad humans anywhere
within Cults it is meaningless
collectivist zealotry so you look at
this crowd in this video what do you
think would happen if say like Andy no
walked through it
assault battery and we know that's true
because it's quite literally what they
did to him imagine what would happen if
someone like billboard Chris walked by
this filming and tried to ask them
questions same story same story and we
know because it's happened to him but
the funny thing is when there was a
trump rally in the Pacific Northwest and
a guy showed up doing Nazi salutes and
screaming racial slurs what did the
Trump supporters do they told him to
leave and he wasn't welcome because he
didn't want the hate
really amazing this is a cult you have
people you know it's fascinating you
have the the the the the saying that you
know a lot of people a lot of
progressives like to say the old world
is dying and the new world struggles to
be born
they're referencing their weird cult
religion trying to emerge but the
reality is the old world is the uniparty
establishment that's been around since
perhaps 1913 or slightly before then and
then implemented with a lot of these
changes we saw over the past Century and
now you have two new worlds trying to be
born the Resurgence of the
constitutional republic or the
progressive neo-marxist Revolution
The Establishment unit party took over a
long time ago and morphed this country
into something grotesque Foreign Wars
for the Empire nation-building garbage
nonsense and now you have with Bernie
Sanders and with Trump These two
factions popping up and trying to
establish their world view
I happen to like the constitutional
republic and the Constitution and the
individual liberties meritocracy uh and
things like that and I'm opposed to
Blind cellatry so it's fascinating that
in this culture War we can hang out with
Sheamus Coughlin a devout Catholic uh
every day on this show for six months
out of the year for the past couple
years and uh we have we'll have
questions and conversations about faith
and religion with smiles on our faces
and then we'll go to Waffle House
afterwards and we'll laugh and make
jokes together because that's what the
constitutional republic was this great
Melting Pot of people trying to
understand each other in their world if
you disagree you are the enemy and they
physically attack you they then accuse
their enemies of being the ones who
physically attack people when they don't
well and and you know this was part of
let's say the old America or a better
America the America of the past is that
rich people and poor people they shared
the same sidewalks they shared the same
restaurants they shared the same bars
they went to the same ball games they
flew on the same Airlines and and that
was it whether you were Rich whether you
were poor whether you were middle class
everybody respected the fact that hey
we're all rich in Freedom and so we can
all share the same things and we can all
get along because we appreciate our
freedoms more than we care about how
much money the guy to my left has or how
poor the guy to my left is and and now
it's this elitism that we see where the
the financial Elite the global Elite
believe that they have the moral High
ground and it's their duty to tell us
how to live and what's what's what's
what's what's really frustrating and I'm
not a big historian but I had you know
I've had people reach out to me and and
Veterans and people and they say Owen
in in my day
we used to invade countries for what
they're doing to you we used to go into
banana republics and and we would shut
that down and we would try to restore a
constitutional republic and so what what
or or maybe even form a democracy as
they would at least used to claim and so
what's frustrating is that we went
through an entire Century of testing
this methodology right what works better
communism or free market capitalism look
at what was built in the west versus the
fall of Russia right or if you want to
maybe a better example look at North
Korea compared to South Korea well now
it's like we have to learn the lessons
of the 20th century all over again yes I
want to I want to show this uh meme real
quick to prove Owen's point
this is uh Christy Yamaguchi main said
the Taco Bell drive through at 1am will
have a 200 000 Mercedes S65 waiting
right behind a 96 Cavalier that's never
had the oil changed followed by a moped
ridden by three people all craving the
same thing to live Moss truly the last
great Melting Pot of class in this
country that's it but that that it's
this is this is literally true because
uh we got a local Taco Bell out here and
I haven't I didn't have Taco Bell in
like a decade and then me and my
girlfriend were driving oh no no the
first step was I was we were Sheamus and
we drove past at Taco Bell and Sheamus
was like he asked us if we wanted to
live moss and we were like I mean Taco
Bell's really good and so I'm in a Tesla
and we pull up behind like a like a
Honda Civic and there's like a Toyota
and it's exactly the story we just
cheesy gordita crunches man those are
good but but that's the thing about
America is that what I truly love about
this country having traveled all over
the world the idea that some working
class do with dirt in his hands can be
standing on the sidewalk when his when
the mayor of this of a city of two
million walks by and he can give them
the middle finger and say F you you're a
scumbag and they can't do anything about
it well not anymore oh now it's okay and
I mean you try that and you're likely to
get arrested right Joe Biden is a
pedophile
wait you're not quoting my sentencing
document
into that yeah look you know we we're
trying to apply logic here right and the
other side is not engaged in logic
whatsoever they're deeply immersed in
ideology of course but what Trump's
ideology for the left is power it's the
pursuit of power it's the acquisition of
power and it's the exercise of power
that is what drives them so what what we
just described with Taco Bell that's the
way America is supposed to be America
has always been an aspirational Society
we don't hate the guy in the Mercedes we
all want to be the guy in the Mercedes
right and Achieve and the left realized
that there was no currency in that so
they realized they cannot gain a
foothold of power in America if we all
loved each other and we're all
aspirational and we all supported each
other
they came right in with divide and
conquer and that's what all of this is
whether it's gender race political
values doesn't matter they have come in
with giant wedges to blow us all apart
and it is in my opinion it's a crime
against you you mentioned race and back
in I think it was probably the 50s hurt
this guy Herbert Mark Hughes you
probably heard his name yeah um Herbert
Marcus pointed out that the
Revolutionary energy was no longer in
the working class because capitalism
delivers the goods your average person
that just that will go to work and you
know not be late and do their job they
won't be poor if you're in America Ben
Shapiro says if you're in America you
finish High School you don't have a kid
outside of marriage and you get a job
and keep it for a couple years you will
not be in poverty in America now this
this the what poverty means to some
people might be different but you're not
going to be destitute you're not going
to be broke you're not going to be
you're not going to be unable to pay
your bills you're not going to be unable
to feed yourself if you follow those
three rules but
the communist or Marquis was saying that
the when the Revolutionary energy was no
longer in the working class you had to
go to you had to go to race to race
basically race Marxism and that's where
all of the intersectional stuff has come
from basically trying to put different
races against each other because when
Society was all focused on everybody
trying to be basically a a classical
liberal trying to better themselves
Society works together when you have
when you have the ability to separate
pieces people by classes then you have
the ability to to cause you know fights
in chaos thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time